[Music]
all right welcome to lecture nine of GD
50 today's topic is dread halls so last
week we ventured into unity our first
foray into 3d and not only 3d but also
just getting our hands around our heads
and hands around the Unity game engine
which is among unreal and others sort of
the most popular game engines in use for
2d and 3d games and last week we did
sort of a 2.5 D style helicopter game
whereby everything was in 3d but we were
still aligning things based on just two
axes the X and the y I believe possibly
the Z and the y I don't remember but two
axes versus three axes today will
actually be diving into using all three
axes available to us in unity 3d in the
context of a game called dread hauls and
so what dread hauls is is a V it was a
VR game actually the first VR game that
I ever played on the oculus the the gear
VR Samsung gear VR and it pits you in
sort of this dark and eerie 3d maze
where you don't really know what's going
on and you can go around and get
collectables and encounter creatures and
stuff as you can see in the bottom right
screen shot there
today's examples gonna be a little
simpler but it allows us to explore
things like procedural maze generation
and first-person camera controls so last
week recall we were using sort of a
three third-person camera whereby we
were sorta far back on the scene today
we'll actually be using a first-person
camera where the camera is effectively
our eyes as if we were walking around in
the maze ourselves unfortunately we
won't be using a VR demonstration this
week but next week I hope to put
together sort of a VR sampling using
this project so we can see how this
works in VR and how unities toolkit
works in VR so some of the topics we'll
be covering today we'll be talking about
texturing so recall last week the
helicopter and all of the items in our
game were just sort of flat colors they
didn't really have any textures
associated with them we'll talk about
how to assign textures to materials and
how to apply those materials to objects
in our scene we'll talk about materials
and lighting so not only materials but
also the different kinds of lights that
unity supports and a few details
about those we'll talk about again 3d
maze generation so we'll have a simple
but effective algorithm for creating a
3d data structure to represent our level
as opposed to previously where we had
just a you know a tile map that we could
generate to give us the appearance of
walking around in some sort of 2d world
now we'll actually perform a similar
operation on data a 2d array but we'll
take that array and will actually create
3d blocks and create a maze that we can
walk through in 3d space which is kind
of fun and interesting last week we only
had one scene in our game so which was
just a play scene and even though we had
sort of like a game over state within
that scene we didn't transition between
scenes we just sort of reloaded the same
scene today we'll have a title screen
and a play scene which sort of is an
evolution of the idea that we had in
love 2d where we had a state machine
that was governing our entire game in
terms of the different states that we
could be in whether it was the title the
game over the place date and so forth
unity does the same thing with scene
objects which are effectively a snapshot
of a series of game objects aligned in a
particular way in the editor we'll talk
about
fog and also global lighting and certain
other things that allow us to create a
atmosphere conducive to the sort of feel
that we want to get in our game today
which is sort of creepy and eerie and
lastly when we talk about how to create
UI elements in the game we'll talk about
unity 2d it's canvas object and text
labels and some other things and how
those all operate which is sort of two
sides of the same coin unity 3d also
comes bundled with unity 2d a set of
tools used to make not only 2d games but
also 2d interfaces that you can apply to
your 3d games so first a demo now I've
been sick for the last week so I'm not
going to ask for anybody to come up in
demo just because I don't wanna get
anybody else sick so I'm going to just
go ahead and show just this lecture the
game that I put together for you so here
I have two scenes notice here I have a
title scene and a place seeing them in
the unity editor right now I'm going to
load up the title scene here which I've
done and then notice that it has sort of
a game view and a scene
view I'm gonna hit play I'm gonna make
sure that it's set to maximize which it
is and so we have sound here so we
should hear audio and hit play and
notice that we have sort of like this
ambient creepy music track playing we
have a very we could have easily done
this in love 2d this is just black
screen with two text labels on it and
this is done with unities 2d UI toolkit
and so it says it tells us to press
ENTER so if I press ENTER we instantly
get teleported into kind of like this
maze this creepy looking maze and so I
can walk around in this maze and there
are a few things going on so anybody can
anybody tell me some of the things they
notice about the scene well what jumps
out at them what are some of the
elements if you were to put this
together yourself where would you start
what are the pieces that we can put
together here yep there has to be a
ground that you can stand on and there
is so we're generating not only walls in
our scene of course but we need a ground
to sit in and obviously and also if you
look up top it's kind of difficult to
tell but we also have a ceiling so
ground in a ceiling and walls some kind
of lighting yes and so in in this case
we're actually using ambient world
lighting as opposed to having a light
source so we'll take a look at that last
in last week's lecture we used or two
weeks Pryor's lecture we used a
directional light object but in this
case we have no lights in the scene
we're actually using unities world
lighting which we'll take a look at soon
when we walk around notice that I can
move my where my camera is looking with
my mouse so we're actually controlling
the camera with a first-person
controller an FPS controller which is
actually a component that unity provides
to you and then notice eventually if we
keep exploring the maze we come across
this little thing here which is a sort
of a pickup and when we pick this up
we get sort of like this piano weird
creepy piano sound and then the scene
reloads anybody notice anything about
what we see in the distance like how
that's how that's affected like if I'm
looking at this wall right here for
example it's kind of hard to tell but as
opposed to like down this hallway what's
what's the difference there the light
source is further away kind of so we're
at what we're experiencing here we're
seeing is it's a a graphics sort of
concept called fog and so what fog lets
you do is it effectively adds color to
the scene based upon how far away the
objects are in the scene and multiplies
color onto them and it gives you the
illusion of looking in looking as if
think you're surrounded by fog basically
and it's been around for a very long
time back even as far as the n64 days
and we'll talk about that later today
and it's actually incredibly easy to add
that into a game with unity and it's
world lighting system any idea as to how
fog not only in terms of aesthetics but
how it could maybe help with performance
you don't need as much pixel clarity
kind of the the big thing about fog and
in the way that it was used a long time
ago is that because eventually things
are completely opaque beyond a certain
point you don't need far draw distance
in your game so you can actually like
dynamically you can you can emit
rendering things that are a certain
distance away because you wouldn't be
able to see them anyway so this was an
optimization technique used a lot
back when draw distance was a huge
bottleneck on computers and gave video
game consoles back in like the 90s for
example like Silent Hill the game for
ps1 was almost exclusively fog and you
can see very little in front of you and
we'll see a screen show that later
and they use that for to boost their
performance and also to provide a
certain aesthetic and then one other
thing you might be paying attention to
is there's a sound on loop just sort of
this creepy sort of whispering sound and
that's to just add atmosphere right just
because without it we would you know
it's little things like that especially
in horror games like this the atmosphere
can be everything so with very simple
ideas fog some whispers first-person
controller sort of tight hallways you
can produce something that's pretty
scary now there are a few things missing
from this namely there's nothing that's
going to come at you and attack you
but it would be not terribly difficult
to add but because we're using
procedural generation you would need
what's called a nav mesh and you would
need to generate that procedurally so
that things could follow you in 3d space
it might have some time to talk about
how to do that a little bit later today
but that's not implemented in this
particular lecture but it would be not
too infeasible to accomplish but those
are some of the pieces that we'll take a
look at today so that was this is the
title scene notice that there's not a
whole lot here actually so if i zoom
back out we can see you know canvases
are huge and unity just because it's
more optimized for the engine to render
them that way
but we can see even though it's a 2d
sort of
you I it's very visible in 3d space and
if it click this button here we end up
getting oh no that's that just brings us
into sorry click this button here that
brings us into sort of the 2d unity 2d
mode so now we're interacting with
things in 2d and I can actually click on
this label and move it around in 2d as
if we were using a 2d game engine as
opposed to a 3d game engine so we'll
look at that a little bit later this is
the just the title scene so the play
scene itself I'm not going to save that
the play scene itself I'm going to go
from 2d back to 3d here is pretty much
empty so we have a first-person
controller here this is the FPS
controller object does anybody anybody
tell what basically constitutes an FPS
controller just by looking at the scene
here what are the some of the pieces
that jump out at you
just put the camera exactly but the
camera right where the player is
effectively where their head should be
relative to where their body is and
their body
what's constituting their body here can
you tell it's this it's actually this
capsule right here if we can see it
there's this capsule here this green
capsule it's a little bit more organic
feeling than a than a cube necessarily
but you could use a cube as well but a
capsule is how character controllers and
unity are represented and character
controllers sort of come for free and
unity which is really nice they're part
of the standard assets so if you go to
import package in unity if you're going
to assets import package there's a lot
of packages that come for free the sort
of bootstrap you notice there's like 2d
packages two cameras characters the
characters package has 3d characters are
third-person characters first-person
characters some that are physics based
some that are not physics based this
particular controller is not physics
based meaning that we don't apply forces
to it we move it around it's kinematic
it can't it is affected by gravity so in
a sense it kind of is physics based but
it's not strictly physics based like a
rigid body and a rigid body would and
the collisions that occur between this
and another rigid body aren't the same
as they would be if we were to make this
a purely rigid body based character
controller there is a purely rigid body
based character controller that you can
import have an experimented with it a
lot but you could probably figure out a
good use for that in terms of a game or
maybe you want to move precisely on
surfaces that have different materials
like icy surfaces or whatnot and have it
apply it in a very physically realistic
way another few things that we have here
in our place scene we have a dungeon
generator object so this dungeon
generator object is just an empty object
with a level generator script here and
then we have a few other objects a floor
parent and walls parent and a whisper
source so we'll get into the details of
what all of those mean our goal today
will be talking about a few things so
we'll be talking about here's a picture
of just our maze so we talked about some
of those things at a high level we'll
actually explore how to
implement them in unity today so making
a maze making the fog effect walking
through it with our character controller
we want to be able to have some kind of
gameplay here so we have collectibles in
the form of this red coin it is actually
part of another standard assets pack
they prototype assets pack it comes with
a prototype little coin object that you
can throw in anybody notice anything
about this coin beyond the fact that
it's you know just a sort of red coin
what it was do you notice about this
scene here submitting a glow any ideas
as to how its emitting a glow the light
source inside of it exactly so we'll
talk about that we'll show you how
that's implemented very easy to do in
unity and then we'll also talk about
towards the end our 2d scene our title
scene and how to construct it which is
actually very easy in unity as opposed
to doing something by code you know very
rarely actually for interfaces need to
touch code at least in terms of how to
lay them out in unity you can do
everything very visually and with the
mouth since actually it's a it's a
pleasure to making interfaces if you're
used to just making them in in code so
texturing so last week or two weeks ago
we did nothing with textures it was well
that's not true we had one texture on
the background which was the sort of
scrolling background but we didn't
really look at that too much in today's
example that you know the helicopter and
the coin and the the buildings and all
that stuff those were all just polygons
with flat colors associated with them
today we'll be talking about how to
actually texture things with materials
and so this is very easy to do in unity
so I'm gonna go over to a to my title
scene here just because it's fairly it's
it's lit in a fairly normal way as
opposed to the place scene which is not
lit in a normal way because we're using
environment lighting we don't have a
skybox the title scene has a fairly
normal light a lighting setup so if I
add a cube here to the scene so we can
see right off the bat by default we do
get a material here which has an L
what's called an albedo component albedo
just means like what's its surface color
look like it has a much more
technical definition and you can look up
on Wikipedia what albedo means it has
something to do with the way that light
interacts with surfaces there's a lot of
other elements here you can make
something look metallic you can make it
look smooth or rough and you can also
add normal maps height maps and a few
other things which gives it more of like
a bumpy texture and so forth and you can
also make things emit light this way
which the coin actually not only emits
light but also is a light source so it
does both and there's a few other things
here for example let's say you have a
very large cube and a small texture if
you put a very small texture on a large
cube what's it gonna look like what's
your instinct if we if we have a very
large cube but a very like say we have a
64 by 64 pixel texture but our cube is
humongous
what's that what effect is that gonna
have on the cube it's gonna look kind of
like an n64 Cube right it's going to
what basically happens is it's going to
interpolate between the texture pixels
that texels when you apply a texture to
your cube and so when you apply a small
texture to a large surface it's gonna
look stretched it's gonna be it's gonna
look stretched and like it's gonna look
also filtered is it like you sort of see
in some YouTube videos if you watch them
and they record at a very small
resolution but you blow them up they
look filtered or if you've ever
stretched a picture in the right
software and it's looked it looks
interpolated and filtered it's gonna
have that look so you can do is you can
apply tiling so here we can see there's
a tiling element x and y so of 1 in the
x and y direction because it only
applies on a flat surface so the effect
of tiling is would be such that if you
have a 64 by 64 texture you could just
tile that texture several times to get
the desired look that you want on
whatever surface that you're trying to
look at in your game world maybe it's a
very small object but maybe it's a very
large object that you're looking at as a
character and you want to tile bricks
for example or you know stone so to
apply a texture to a
to a 3d object in the scene I'm gonna go
into here so you need a material first
and so these are all unity material
objects you can tell because they have a
circular layout localize if they've been
wrapped around a sphere these are all
unity materials as opposed to textures
textures are just 2d object to D you
know textures to the images so this is
part of a an asset pack that I
downloaded for this lecture called
dungeon modules low poly dungeon modules
which is in the asset store and so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
apply let's say I want to just apply
this rock material to this object right
and I go over to that I'm going to first
add a I think because I went into the
material had a incorrect appearance so
do that oh that's strange
I'm gonna create a new scene and then
I'm going to add a cube and then a not
pop but maybe the beam I wonder why it
is not that's very strange for some
reason it might be a setting that I have
enabled that's not allowing it to
correctly render but the effect of that
should be that we apply normally if you
apply a texture to a material it'll have
the effect of creating it'll it'll
instantly texture it but what I can do
is I can go to textures here and this
should work too I can go to that and
then it'll apply it that way so normally
if you're in a fresh project and you add
a new 3d object and you just click and
drag a material onto a 3d object it will
texture it for you in this case I think
because it's automatically assigning a
material to these objects based on some
project setting that I'm off the off the
cuff just unable to I don't know for
sure you can instead just go to the
albedo component here so I'll Beatle
functions not only as a color but also
as a texture for your object and so you
can apply a texture just a 2d image to
your albedo component of a material
right and that'll have the same effect
as ten
string it immediately so normally what
if this is supposed to do is create a
albedo create a new material with that
texture as the albedo when you set a
material to the 3d object now I wonder
if I yeah I'm not sure I'm gonna show
exactly why it didn't work as like right
off the bat like it's normally supposed
to and a fresh project it will I'll try
to investigate but if it ever happens
like that where for some reason your I
think it has to do with the way the
shaders are set on here maybe there's a
setting I'm just not sure about but you
can just set the albedo component here
manually and it'll have the same effect
so the albedo component of your material
setting that with a texture textures
objects and so that's effectively how we
get from this sort of look of a flat
shaded or flat color shaded object to a
texture shaded object just like that and
texture mapping sort of in itself is a
very wide field and fairly complicated
but ultimately it looks something like
this so does anybody can anybody tell me
what this looks like here so we see here
obviously we have a fully Mattia
textured model but if we're looking at
this what does it look like we've done
here
so what does it look like ignore all the
lines but what does it sort of look like
we have on this surface just a texture
right we can see whoops we can sort of
see the colors here for example maybe
the his belt here or or actually that
looks like the top of his head here this
being the top of his head and then we
have like his belt and other things this
right here we can pretty clearly see
that's like sort of his face mask right
but it's just on a 2d surface like this
is a just a regular texture and so what
we've done here is basically taking all
of the polygons that comprise the model
and sort of laid them out flat right we
lay them out flat as if on a table where
our texture is and that's what UV
mapping is and this is usually something
that you do in whatever 3d modeling
software that you're using in unity when
you apply a texture to a material or a
material with a texture to an object it
will use its standard it has its own
built-in like mapping algorithm that'll
apply material to a model and so it does
it differently for different objects we
can we can create a like a sphere for
example move the sphere over here and
I'm gonna try again and just to see if
the applying of the material works on
that not doesn't so applying a so if we
go into this material here which is for
some reason greyed out new scene again
create a new 3d sphere and then
oh this time it looks like it so I can't
tell no I don't think that's working oh
now it's now it allows us to accept a
texture okay so we can apply a texture
it whoops apply a texture to that and so
now we can see our sphere has been
mapped as well and it looks fairly
convincing it's been wrapped around in a
way that doesn't look too distorted or
too weird and so unity has its own ways
of mapping for its primitive objects
whether it's spheres cubes we have a few
other ones capsule cylinders planes and
it will depend obviously on where your
texture is if your texture is fairly or
nate's it might end up looking distorted
but for most purposes for simple
primitive objects for most textures it
should work pretty well now if you
imported a model that was like a table
or a character and you just applied a
texture to it it's not going to look
good it's going to look messed up and so
your 3d software will export a material
with the model assuming that you've
modeled in that software with a texture
it'll actually give you a material that
you can then reference that will
properly apply a texture to your
character but the same sort of apply a
texture just a regular texture to a
complicated model just isn't going to
work because it hasn't been UV mapped in
a smart way
Unity's not going to know I have a table
I want to map I want to map the texture
to the table in a you know in a way that
looks convincing you can see this kind
of if we create a cube and then if we go
ahead and I've been making it apparent
for some reason if we go up here I'm
gonna first assign okay for some reason
that worked instantly but you can see
we've applied a sort of wall texture to
it and then if we scale it down so this
is the scale button up here so we have
you can move rotate things if unfamiliar
the sort of these top buttons up here
are transform operators so you can move
things scale our rotate things and scale
things so if you scale this along the
you know this y-axis a bit and then you
zoom in the texture looks pretty
compressed and distorted because it's
just doing the same algorithm and
assuming it's the same kind of surface
without taking into consideration how
it's been warped right so it ideally you
wouldn't have these sort of like
flattening thing this this flattening
happening and so in your 3d software you
would unwrap your model and then apply a
texture to each separate polygon of your
model in a way that looks convincing and
so this isn't anything that you
necessarily have to do for the lectures
or for the demonstration for your
project but if you are creating your own
3d assets if you're importing 3d assets
and if you want to use textures in a way
that we're doing today you will need to
probably become familiar with you the
wrapping you the unwrapping UV mapping
in whatever software that you're using
and if you're just unfamiliar with it in
general and have wanted to know sort of
what goes on in turning a you know flat
white polygon character into something
that has a texture this is effectively
what happens you unwrap it make it flat
sort of like stamp the material onto it
effectively and that be they know that
map's the UVs of the texture sort of the
textures virtual coordinates to your 3d
model so any questions as to how this
works at all or about unity and applying
textures
you make the textures right where it's
kind of like how do you make the
textures on the right that I mean that's
kind of an art form in itself you you do
have to do it by hand and sort of know I
mean there's a good amount of trial and
error that'll go into it too as you're
making your model and sort of unwrapping
it and those saying oh this looks weird
as I'm applying this polygon to the
surface I'm gonna go ahead and change
the texture but you could use any you
could use [ __ ] or Photoshop or any
standard texture creation software and
kind of just as something that I don't
do a lot of it but it's something that I
imagine that you just get better with at
with time and artists texture artists
and modeling artists probably develop
sort of like in a tuned sense of what
makes a good texture versus what doesn't
generally you'll make the model first
and then you'll make the texture so okay
so we already talked a little bit about
models sorry about materials we'll go
back over it really briefly again there
there is a resource that I really like
and I think does a really wonderful job
of teaching beyond far beyond the basics
of unity and that's cat like coding comm
and it's totally free they just have a
bunch of free articles on there which
are very in-depth and this is a
screenshot taken from one of the
articles where they talked about how to
make really interesting materials so we
can see here this one on the left it
looks a very you know it looks like a
fireball like it's made out of magma and
it's got bumps on it it has contour you
can see that there's sort of like a glow
to the fire on it on the right you can
see that this model has sort of
conditional shine on certain parts of it
like the metal part of it is shiny but
the rest of it isn't and sort of like
how do we make certain parts of the
material shiny how do we make certain
parts of it flat the article goes into
depth on that and effectively what they
do is they use several layers of maps
like a shininess map which is a texture
that tells that you reference in a unity
custom
that you write which the article teaches
you how to write which will make certain
parts of the texture glossy and certain
parts of it not glossy so matte and so
you can do a lot of really cool very
interesting things in unities shading
system is very sort of the sky is the
limit I mean because it's effectively a
standard shader language like you would
it's effectively the same thing as hlsl
I believe which is high level shading
language which is a if I'm not missing
Microsoft originally came up with it and
it's very similar to GLSL which is the
OpenGL shading language and so what
these are effectively is just little
programs that run on your graphics card
we talked about this before but they
tell your scene how to process lighting
for the objects that are within it and
everything in unity has a shader
associated with it even if it's just the
standard shader which by default is just
a white color but you can write your own
shaders and you're capable of virtually
unlimited possibility and the this is
effectively is all a shader and it's all
a shader that's been written in code but
we have a lot of these variables that
are exposed to us and albedo is one of
them and albedo is sort of conditional
if it if it gets a texture applied to it
it will just render that texture but if
you apply a color to it it will apply
that color to your material and so
that's how you can get you know textured
things versus non textured things
metallic just computes shininess and
reflectivity off of surfaces and that's
just something that's written into the
shader and produces the lighting
responsible to make that happen and all
of these different things are just part
of a single shader and a material is
effectively a shader they're kind of one
in the same a material is a little bit
different in that you can also specify
how its surface should interact with
other things so for example if you're in
an ice level a material can not only be
like the Glatt the sort of glassy icy
look of something but also how slippery
is it when I walk over it and should I
slide and how should other things
interact with it that have physics so
like those two sort of hand-in-hand or
sort what a material is
but likely as you're starting out the
only real things that you'll need to
consider and you sort of bound only by
your curiosity are albedo and maybe
metallic and maybe a mission and then
depending on how much you how big your
thing is and how smaller your texture is
maybe tiling and then recall last week
we manipulated offset so offset is how
much the texture is shifted and recall
it loops around back to the other side
and so by manipulating offset on the
x-axis we were able to get a scrolling
infinitely scrolling texture right and
so all these things have their uses and
pretty much everything in unity has its
uses it's a very vast toolkit to use but
those are probably the important things
that you'll see and this article and
many others on this website which I
highly recommend if you're looking to
get really deep into unity will give you
a lot of insight into how things work
far beyond just the surface level there
so any questions on materials alright so
we're gonna take a look now at lighting
so materials materials are one part of
the equation so that's sort of defines
how things should look when light hits
them but we also need light itself in
our scene to illuminate things and so
this is taken from another article on
cat light coding on rendering and so
this is a scene with a lot of lights a
lot of glowing lights emissive lights
and there's a lot more going on here but
this is a another great series of
articles on how to understand the
lighting model in unity and it teaches
you a lot it teaches you almost you know
down to the very bare ingredients of the
sort of the software and the rendering
if you want to go that deep I certainly
haven't gone through every article
because there's just a tremendous amount
of content it's very deep but if you're
looking to really looking to really get
a sense of how it works
I would I would encourage you to explore
that so we'll look at a few different
types of lighting beyond the more
complicated things that this article
talks about we'll look at the different
styles of lights which you'll probably
use more often as you're starting out so
point lights anybody have an idea so
what a point light might be based on
this picture
it's not pointing in a very specific
direction that's actually a spotlight so
a point light is a set a source of light
that actually shoots out in all
directions around it so in emits light
in all directions but within a confined
area and a specific intensity a spot
light shines light in a specific
direction so only one direction and
what's interesting about spotlights is
you can actually apply what's called a
cookie to them and what a cookie does
very similar to what the bat like the
Batman light does it allows you to apply
a texture to a light and therefore cast
shadows specific shadows on the light so
if you wanted to make like something
like the bat signal you could put the
bat man icon cookie on your spotlight
and that'll shine the light but the bat
the Batman logo will be in the middle of
it it's effectively the same thing as
taking a literal spotlight and putting a
object onto it it produces a shadow a
manual shadow it's called a cookie yep a
directional light so anybody know what a
directional light is so despite its name
it's actually not not the same thing as
a spotlight so a directional light we
use the directional light last week
actually last lecture directional light
casts light in a single direction but
throughout the entire scene as if it's
the Sun so this allows us to illuminate
globally the entire scene but all light
gets cast from one direction so if you
want to produce the appearance of
daylight in your scene just a single
directional light will illuminate
everything and then the last thing which
is used less is called an area light so
does anybody know can anybody guess when
area light is based on this picture here
yes light that's only on the surface
kind of yes so it's light that will emit
from the surface of a specifically
designated rectangle effectively in one
direction so you can define a large area
for example maybe like maybe you want
like a wall strip in your game or
something along the wall to emit light
specifically to the left or something
like that
that's what an area light is capable of
now area lights are computationally
expensive and so you can only use them
when you bake your lighting does anybody
remember what baking means or referring
to lighting so baked lighting just means
that instead of real-time lighting
calculating things dynamically the light
gets calculated one time and saved and
almost like freezed
onto all of the objects in the scene and
so there are pros and cons to this
what's a pro to baked lighting do we
think less computationally intensive
what's a downside to baked lighting
can be dynamically affected so if you're
walking through a baked lighting scene
and you're expecting to cast a shadow on
something or for something to cast a
shadow onto you it's not gonna happen
because the environments already been
the lighting for that scenes been
pre-baked it's almost as if we've just
recolored the world in a specific way
but we're not actually doing any
lighting calculations but this is how
lighting worked in like the n64 era and
it's how it still works now for certain
situations you know nothing's gonna cast
a shadow on something you can make
really nice looking lighting for a scene
without needing to do it in real time
you can just bake it right so those are
the different types of lights so we can
see that in unity so if we go here I'm
going to so right now we have a
directional light so this directional
light is this object here by default all
and you can zoom in as much as you want
but it's sort of like now there we go
this directional light is only shining
in one direction so I can move it here
so currently I'm in it's a little bit
weird to navigate just because it's been
rotated a little bit given that it's a
directional light its rotation so notice
how it changes so if I shine it upwards
notice that everything comes black
because the lighting is just shining
upwards right so as if it's coming from
below and if I shine it towards there
notice that the the lighting on the the
sphere and the little cube there sort of
change a bit right because they're
getting affected by the direction of the
light a little bit but they both get
affected the exact same because they'll
the directional light is omnipresent
it's throughout the entire scene it's a
global object now if I delete the
directional light this we have no light
now so these things just look kind of
like statically shaded you can add a new
light through if you right-click in your
sort of game object view and then you go
over here you can see we have all the
different lights we talked about there's
also things called reflection probes and
light probe groups and those are a
little bit more complicated but those
allow you to effectively get pseudo
real-time lighting and reflection with
baked lighting and reflection we won't
talk about those in today's let
sure but here's a point light for
example so let's see where is it that's
right over here so I'm going to move it
over here so you can see it's not global
like the directional light was right
it's just affecting this very limited
I'm going to zoom in a little bit so you
can see a little bit better but it's
affecting just sort of these two objects
relative to where its position is right
and so this works perfectly for things
like lamps and your scene if you want to
have a street light or whether you want
to have maybe like a fire going on in a
house or if you want the you know like
the power up that we had in the or the
pickup that we had in the unity scene
right we have just the it's just
emitting a purple light that is within a
very small radius notice here we can
change the color of the light so if I
make it like that some reason oh there
you go
so do that so notice now it's emitting a
purple light so you can color a light
however you want to produce whatever
effects you want so fire is not going to
emit white light it's probably gonna
admit like an orange red light street
lights are probably going to emit kind
of like a yellow orange e light so
depending on what your scene looks like
and what you're trying to emulate you
can accomplish pretty much anything with
just the you know these very simple
objects so I'm gonna get rid of the
point light and then we're going to
create a spotlight I'm not going to
create a area light just because we need
to Bay actually baked the lighting into
the scene but I will create a spotlight
just so we can see what it looks like
get it in the right position
someone's getting a little tough to uh
fare it exactly where you are okay get
him close there we go perfect so there's
a little spotlight right here is being
produced by our objects so we can see we
can move it around and then we can apply
a cookie to it if we want to as well
it's right here so in your if you're in
a spotlight and you want to apply a
texture to it just this little cookie
and it just expects a texture so
whatever whatever image you want and if
you're creating a cookie texture white
means full lights and black means full
shadow and so you can make it a
grayscale image you can make it anywhere
in between white and black which will
allow you to produce some interesting
effects the for example the manual in
it's not here it's not I didn't include
the picture here but the manual shows
like there are some kind of like the
lights that you put on a stand and they
have a bunch of LEDs right and they're
serving a grid and they shoot out a
spotlight you can create a cookie that's
kind of a grayscale with those gridded
lines and it will shoot light onto the
scene as if it's being broadcast from a
sort of grid of LEDs so there's a lot
you can do with just some very simple
ideas those are the kinds of lighting
that we can use and in today's lecture
we only really use the point light and
in last lecture we use the directional
light and spotlights you can you could
for example programmatically change for
example the rotation of a spotlight if
you want to have like a swinging
spotlight and you're seeing to
illuminate some wall or some surface
there's a lot of cool things you could
do with it
so those are the core types of lights in
unity does anybody have any questions as
to how they're used or how they work
it does not matter so for the
directional light it does not matter
where it's placed you could place it
anywhere in your scene zero zero or some
far distance away you'll have the exact
same effect on the entire scene
any more questions okay cool cool so
those are lights bump mapping talked
about very briefly so a bump mapping is
we actually do use this in the game the
a bump map effectively is so what you
see here on the left is a in actual 3d
scene these are actual models being
shaded in real time in real time but
there are actually real models being
illuminated in the middle we can see
what's called a bump map and on the
right we can see a just just a flat like
a flat plane with a bump map with that
same bump map applied to it and then
illuminate it so what a bump map allows
us to do is to take a flat wall or flat
surface or whatever you want and then
simulate like an actual
three-dimensional contour three
dimensional bumps or whatever you want
on that surface without needing to
create the actual geometry to make it
possible and so there are different
tools that will allow you to create bump
mapping objects off our bump mapping
textures often 3d packages will have
these so you can create them or other
software but they are effectively just
the encoding of what are called surface
normals so just a vector going from
outside of the outside of the polygons
at that given point and they tell the
lighting system in unity pretend as if
there's actually geometry pointed in
that direction when you calculate it and
so even though it doesn't distort the
geometry in a way that's like this is
still completely flat the lighting
thinks that the geometry is kind of you
know contoured and so it allows us to
create this is kind of a toy example but
it's actually relevant in the in the
case of walls that have and we covered
this last week just not as much detail
but walls that you want to be flat and
you don't want to have a lot of polygons
for you can create a bump map for and
apply that bump map and then when you're
rendering it when you walk past a wall
it's gonna look as if the wall actually
has cracks and bumps in it for a
realistic effect and this is used in the
game to a slight degree and you can
crank it up if you want to I didn't on
my computer because my settings or my
specs aren't sufficient but every
texture in today's example has a bump
map associated with it so you can
actually see where what the you can
actually see the effect of bum mapping
at various degrees of of use the
materials here so I'm going to go I'm
going to load up the scene that has the
actual
stuff I'm going to actually I don't need
to love to see and all I need to do is
go to the materials and the floor for
example where's the floor right here so
notice that before we talked about
albedo and then I also mentioned normal
map so right here all you really need to
do in order to get unity to detect
normal maps and this is just part of the
standard shader normal maps and bump
maps by the way are effectively
synonymous you can just drag your normal
map texture into this field here this
little square and then give it a degree
I wish to apply that normal map and so
if you look at this here I might be able
to see I don't recall yeah we can sort
of see how it changes the texture right
so at zero there's no normal mapping
taking place at all that texture is just
completely flat as if we have done just
a regular apply texture to a sphere but
the degree at which we apply a normal
mapping so notice that degree 1 it kind
of looks pretty realistic as if we've
got kind of a stony texture and the more
we go right the more exaggerated it
starts to look right and you can just
keep doing that and it'll eventually
just look really distorted but that
allows you and depending on how strong
your computer is you can go higher or
lower to affect just how bumpy
just how strong the bump map the normal
map affects the lighting rendering so
it's that easy to get just a fairly sort
of extra sense of realism in your scene
so you'll notice if you're walking
through the scene if you turn off
lighting it's even easier to see all of
the surfaces the floors the ceilings and
the walls have a bump map as well as a
texture map so that's in case you're
wondering what these weird colored
textures are RGB are X Y Z for the
surface normals and how and they're
permutations thereof and that's how it
gets encoded into this and so often you
can see if you're looking at a bump map
and a texture map you can kind of see
together like okay this makes sense the
parts that I would expect to be bumpy or
do have a correlation to how they look
on the actual bump map texture you can
see it here everything that is bumpy or
contoured is very visible in the bump
map that's just by nature of the way the
data is encoded so any questions as to
how bump Maps work or what they are or
how to use them in unity alright cool so
now we're gonna start getting into a
little bit more into how this all comes
together in our maze on our game and
we'll talk about maze generation so I'm
going to just start up the game the
scene here so I'm in the actual place
scene so in scenes I loaded up play as
before I'm gonna hit play I'm gonna turn
off my sound just because the creepy
sound is a little disorienting after a
while and then I'm going to I know
actually I'm going to go to a 2 by 3
view and then hit play so we have the
regular game view down here below and
then also if i zoom out you can see that
our scene was empty before but now we've
got a maze and currently it's not very
visible at all because one we're playing
fog right and recall fog allows us to
effectively add color to objects that
are farther away from us
and to there's a ceiling on top of our a
roof on top of our maze so it's black
Chua Lee blocking out with actual what
the maze looks like so we can fairly
easily make a couple of changes here in
order to see our maze a little bit
better so I'm going to go to window I'm
gonna go to lighting settings and so if
you go to window lighting settings those
are your sort of global unity lighting
settings right you can set your sky box
you can set environment lighting you can
set things like fog you can just choose
how things are baked there's a lot of
things here we won't cover nearly all of
them we will cover a few of them
environment lighting is a big one that's
actually how we're lighting the scene in
this game so all the lighting that's not
available all the lighting is
environment lighting that's how we're
doing it we're doing it with color so
notice that you can choose skybox
gradient and color so if you choose
skybox
environment lighting it's gonna have
sort of like it's gonna look kind of
like this
skybox that we have here right this
serve in the far distance looks blue
kind of us a little bit more natural but
I didn't but it when it's applied to our
scene it doesn't look quite the way we
want it to look so we instead was just
color and I chose this sort of murky
greenish brownish color and that gave
the result that I was looking for but
you can make this any color you want to
we can make this some sort of bright
yellow color I have no idea what this is
gonna look like this is probably gonna
look horrible but yep I mean actually
this in a weird way this kind of looks
interesting this actually looks closer
to the original dred halls game than
what I did but it's not very scary kind
looks like we're in a pyramid that is am
i able to go back no okay well I screwed
up the color that we're trying to find
kind of what color I had before it's
kind of like a nasty green kind of like
that it's probably good enough okay
something like that
and so we play it again we could see you
know we're back to the nasty dark color
but that's environment lighting so it
applies a lighting uniform just ambience
kind of like a directional light but it
doesn't have a direction it's just
to everything in your scene at a given
intensity and that that is how we are
lighting our scene that's it's that easy
just environment lighting in our scene
on our lighting scene window now the
other important thing here is the fog so
fog is as easy almost as easy as just
clicking this button here that says fog
and then choosing a color for it
probably you can choose the density so
obviously if it's a higher density fog
it's gonna look as if you're in a foggy
or place like it's going to some the
color to things that are closer to you
faster than it would if you had a lower
density fog and there's some other
features here some of which I'm not
terribly familiar with but for the sake
of today's example just the click
mixture fog is selected and then click
make sure you have the right color for
your fog so if you have like a
ridiculous red color for your fog it's
probably gonna look weird yep but you
can see how you could do all kinds of
weird effects just by adding these
things together like if you want to have
the effect of being in some sort of like
I don't know noxious foreign world maybe
you want like a purple fog instead of
like a dark green fog or whatever that's
you know it's super easy you produce a
lot of very basic but effective effects
that way I find I think it was just that
kind of the same nasty green color so to
bring up this lighting screen all you
need to go do is if you're on a Mac I
think if wind is the same thing there's
a window option in the top menu window
and then lighting here and then settings
and so this will bring you to all of the
settings that are pertinent to at least
today's example and so we're not using
any lights in our scene that we talked
about before at least for the lighting
of the scene itself now there are there
are point lights being used for the
pickups and I'll show you that a second
but what I wanted to illustrate was how
we can sort of look at our maze as after
it's been generated and so what we need
to do first notice that before we were
kind of we couldn't really see our maze
at a distance it was just purely dark
green because of the fog it was adding
green to that
geometry because it's so far away so I'm
gonna disable fog for now it'll actually
remember your settings which is kind of
nice so just going to disable fog and
I'm going to actually add a directional
light to the scene so I'm gonna go here
at a directional light and then I'm
gonna hit play again so now our scene is
lit and you know it looks a lot
different lot less scary and we can see
our maze a lot better we can actually
see that it is a collection of blocks
it's all it's tiled blocks now we can't
see into the maze because the maze has a
roof so what I did was I just made a
generate roof an option in the script
and so if you unselect that and then we
try again now we can see our maze so
this is what our mazes look like and so
the cool thing about unity which I
really love there's just this ability to
look through your scene independent of
the actual game just to like help debug
like it's hard to know if you're
generating your maze correctly when
you're creating it in 3d you know in 2d
you can easily just look at it but in 3d
if especially in a first-person game you
can't really see it so being able to
split your view like this the scene and
the game and actually see oh my
algorithm is working or it's not working
it's super helpful so we can see that it
is carving a maze for us it looks a
little bit weird it's not a traditional
maze in the sense that it has the you
know the classic maze shape to it but it
effectively functions as a maze and it
whoa and it works very well for its
intended purpose and the algorithm is
incredibly simple and we'll talk about
that so that's our maze I'm gonna go
ahead and revert all of the I think if I
just reload the scene it should just
revert it
don't save yep okay so everything's been
reverted all the lighting everything
just gonna do a sanity check and make
sure yep everything works perfectly
we'll
so anybody have any ideas as to where to
get started if we were to implement a 3d
maze yes so create an array populate it
with X's where you want which data
wherever you want something to be
instantiated then loop over it and
instantiate everything exactly how it
works now in terms of actually creating
the maze do you have an idea as to what
how would you go about implementing a
simple maze generator in a there are
obviously very complicated maze
generation algorithms so I like nothing
terribly fancy but just a simple how
would you make a maze it's random
so starting with the idea that we have
an array right it's gonna be a 2d array
because we have two axes upon which
we're generating things here even though
we're in a 3d environment we don't need
a 3d array we just need a 2d array
because if there is a positive value for
wherever we want to generate a block in
our 3d or 3d maze we just generate a
column of block so we don't need to
worry about a third dimension right our
maze isn't like taking into
consideration like multiple levels at
which point we would need to maybe
consider three dimensions I'm even still
you can still divide those into separate
2d arrays of mazes we just have an X and
a Y so how would we get started what
would we start populating the array
let's say we have an array it's just
bunch of zeros right where we pop it in
with the array after after we have
initialized it
thinking maybe you could kind of start
off with so start with a bunch of walls
and then add quarters that's exactly
what we do the algorithm is actually
pretty simple so I'll try and maybe draw
a little bit just to see if it can
illustrate how this works by making sure
that every thing that you change is
orthogonal every block every step that
you move is orthogonal that will that
will ensure that you start at one point
and another point and those points will
always be accessible to one another just
by virtue of how simple the algorithm is
and the orthogonality of it so if we
start with walls so 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 these
are all in the in the distro these are
all boolean x' because we don't need we
only need zeros and one so we're just
gonna use true and false we don't need
to use integers for that so this is our
starting maze here and actually I'm
going to add another dimension because
or not another dimension but another
size just because though the walls
always need to stick to be there these
these are basically untouchable I'm
going to try and draw that as best I can
right
so we effectively have this as our
working area for creating a maze right
because we want this to be we want walls
no matter what because you don't want
our person to be able to walk outside
the maze or see the outside world ever
we want them to be locked in so we have
all of these ones here these truths
effectively and so all we need to do is
start like at some random position let's
say this value at three two or well it's
actually technically it's two three
because we go we index at Y and then X
and a 2d array so we go to three go here
and then we basically can move either
left or you can move either left or
right or up or down well we can't move
both at the same time and why can't we
move both at the same time
let's say that we're let's say it first
of all let me say that we're let's say
we're going to carve our way through the
maze right so we're going to turn these
ones into zeros but we can only move
either we can only move orthogonal a
meaning left or right up or down
we can't move to agonal e so we can only
let's say we have a an X move right and
a Y move
and those can be set to but by default
they're zero so we're basically saying
we're on this step of the generation are
we going to move and actually
technically its direction because we're
the way that we do it is via directions
yeah yes so if you're here
and they move down this is going to be
zero this is going to be zero and so
those points are linked and then from
there we're gonna move in in a given
direction and so all of those let's say
we move here all of those are gonna be
linked and so if we move here
all of those are gonna be linked just by
virtue of the fact that we're moving
orthogonal e we will we can't create a
maze that's unreachable because the way
that just by virtue of the fact they are
moving an elf orthogonal now if we move
diagonally if I were to move here right
there's walls right here and then two
spaces there that's not gonna work
because we can't access that we see it
we're gonna see a cube here and a cube
here and we're gonna see we won't be
able to get move diagonally through
walls right that's why we need to ensure
that we only move either in the X or Y
direction not both at once and so what
the algorithm does is it randomly
chooses should I move X or should I move
Y and should it move positive or
negative so do math dot random equal you
know two equals one effectively in the
code it's random value less than 0.5
because random value in unity gives you
zero to one as a float so you say if
random value less than 0.5 which is a
random chance between you know true and
false effectively 50% move and X
removing Y and then same thing but
should I move in the negative or
positive direction right so if I'm here
I'm thinking okay let's say X move or Y
move it's again it's gonna be an X move
so I'm gonna move either left or right
okay so am I gonna move either negative
one or one step one to the right or to
the left right so if it's negative one
and that's gonna move to the left right
and if it's positive one it's going to
move to the right so I mean that's the
essence of the algorithm just looped
over a bunch of times whenever I move to
another tile turn that into a zero so
actually this becomes a zero change the
color so this will become a zero right
so that's now as empty space and in the
code that instantly teleports the
character to that space too so we know
that our character is always going to be
in an empty space because he gets placed
in the first open space that gets
generated in the maze and so let's say X
move is equal to negative one on this
iteration so let's say we're looping
until we've cleared X blocks so I want
to clear it let's say I want to clear
five blocks so to clear equals five
right that's how many blocks when we've
cleared that many blocks we're done with
the maze generator right so cleared one
so our current counter is 1 so X we get
flip a coin we're moving to the
x-direction by negative one so we move
to here and then we turn this into a
zero
now this implementation of the algorithm
moves one step at a time and so because
of its randomness what this ends up
doing is it produces very large chunks
of deformed spaceship because the
crawler is just constantly moving around
kind of like haphazardly so what's a
refinement that we can make this
algorithm to make it look a little bit
more like corridors or like hallways
you could do that yeah keep going until
you hit the other wall the result of
that you mean hit the like the side of
the maze yeah cuz it well if he did that
it would effectively just be like it
would kind of be I might work in some
cases but it will be very long hallways
and not a lot of like turns or anything
like that so the result what we actually
want to do is when we flip a coin and we
say X move or Y move we want to also say
x to move we want to create a new
variable called number of times to move
effectively right to move and then we
just set that to a random number between
1 so we're gonna move one tile or the
size of the maze minus 2 right taking a
consideration both walls right so let's
say we get the let's say we let's say we
did X move minus 1 and it and we only
got to move equal to 1 right so we only
move here and move once in this
direction so we've got 2 spaces and then
let's say we flip a coin again and then
we got Y move right positive 1 and then
to move we got 2 right so we're gonna
move two directions in the y axis by 1
so it's as a result of us going down
here so we go 0 and then 0 right and so
the effect of this is that we move we
can move in more than just one block at
a time and avoid the sort of random like
haphazard weird organic large room
aesthetic that we want if we want like a
hallway grid like dungeon looking like
room generator right now there's a
caveat to this and that is if we start
here for example and then we want to
let's say we flip a coin it's X move but
it's positive like positive for right we
can't obviously move four tiles to the
right
because one it will go into our walls on
the outside and two it's actually beyond
the bounds of our array so we need to
clamp that value down when we add one to
our value to whatever our X we have to
basically keep pointers right we keep
pointer to whichever tile we're
currently at we need to keep when we
actually go to the next tile in our step
we need to clamp that value within the
range of our walls so we need to clamp
between one so because we don't want to
be at zero we want to clamp it between
one and may size - - two actually
because we want to make sure that we
don't go any farther than the this one
here does that make sense this this is
how that is effectively how our
generator works it's a step beyond just
the move one block at a time just
because the mazes look way too empty and
weird with this approach where you're
moving in a direction and for a random
number of tiles as opposed to just one
tile at a time you actually get pretty
nice-looking simple mazes
this isn't how like actual maze
generation works for mazes that you
would see in like an actual maze that
you do on like a crossword puzzle book
or a maze book or something those are
more complicated but this solution works
well it's very fast and very cheap and
actually pretty simple to understand so
any questions as to how the maze
generator the algorithm at least is
applied to our 2d array works all right
cool that's the that's basically the
gist of it so we're gonna take a break
here for about five minutes and then as
soon as we get back we'll dive a little
bit more into sort of how the character
controller works and the pickup and a
few other aspects of the game all right
welcome back to lecture 9 so before the
break we were talking about the way that
we implemented procedural maize
generation so a fairly simple algorithm
that creates this sort of hallway look
where we can easily get lost but they
aren't technically mazes in the
traditional sense like you might have
seen growing up in puzzle books and such
another pitch for cat-like coding
because the articles are amazing he has
another one on how he did a maze
generator and this one beyond just
regular blocks oh I'm sorry I didn't
have the slide there on the thing so
this is a screenshot of another article
from Cal at coding where he talks about
how to make his own maze generator and
the cool thing about his is that he has
a bunch of different geometry involved
in the scene it's not just blocks
he has doors and windows and other
things and his algorithm is a little bit
different than mine and produces some
pretty interesting looking things you
can see here also it has a view of the
scene sort of superimposed on the actual
scene which he does with a trick using
two cameras so oh so here's another maze
slash dungeon generator article that I
really like where he creates sort of
like Dungeons & Dragons style generators
and this is Sur pertinent to my
interests as a developer because I
really love roguelikes and Dungeon
generators and RPGs but he goes into
extensive detail on how to make a really
nice and efficient 2d may slash dungeon
generator that produces really
nice-looking dungeons as you can see
here it's got a very variable layout
lots of corridors and rooms and stuff
like that so implementing something like
this in unity would be really cool and
there's a plethora of generators and
assets like this that'll do the same
kind of thing in unity available in the
asset store so you don't have to make
this yourself most the time you can
create you can just go find either free
or paid assets that will do all this for
you and save you a tremendous amount of
time and much of them are also very
customizable too so that you can tailor
the generator to fit the domain of your
game so we saw how the lighting works in
our game we've seen the maze sort of how
its generated what it looks like we have
not taken a look yet at the character
controller so we'll briefly just take a
look at that it's actually incredibly
easy to do in unity at least to get
something fairly basic up and running
the way that we get a FPS controller in
the case of our game is unity has which
I alluded to before a set of custom are
built in standard s
packs that allow people getting used to
the game engine or I'm just trying to
bootstrap their game up and running with
some very basic components very basic
things that are super helpful for just
sort of getting a game running so
actually we use the prototyping standard
SS pack for our pickup we use the
characters one for the character
controller the FPS controller so if you
if you're in a fresh project and you
just go to import package and import
this characters thing here it'll import
it into your game so you can immediately
use the prefabs that it gives you to
create a character object so it'll by
default just put it in your assets
folder underneath standard assets and
then characters and then there's a
first-person folder and within the
first-person folder there's a prefabs
folder with it which has the FPS
controller game object and so all you
need to do is just drag it into the
scene and then that becomes your default
camera so that comes with it comes with
unity correct that's just a standard
asset it's always in the the FPS
controller will always be in the so you
have to import it first you have to
import the asset package the characters
package once you've imported the
characters package you'll go into
standard assets in your assets folder
there'll be a new folder called standard
assets within standard assets you'll go
to characters then first person and then
prefabs and that's where you'll find the
FPS controller yes no problem
so the FPS controller if we take a look
at it we talked about it before briefly
but effectively it's just a capsule
Collider which is sort of defying
physics because it's kinematic kinematic
with gravity applied to it and it has a
camera sort of on towards the top of it
where the head is to simulate the
perspective of somebody from
first-person view and there's some
programming involved that allows you to
control it with the keys and the mouse
to control the cameras rotation with the
mouse and the position of the collider
with the WASD keys and if you want you
can dig into the actual script for it -
they're all Bill
included with the standard assets pack
when you import that into your project
it comes all the scripts that make all
that possible
I haven't dug through all of them in too
much detail but it's all there for you
if curious as to how it works and so if
you want to get just a simple you know
FPS controller in your game the
character in your game to walk around
and you know play a first-person game
it's takes about a minute to get up and
running now there's a lot of
customization that you can apply to your
character controller to make it not just
the standard basic character right so
you can set a walk speed you can set a
run speed you can set jump speed you can
you know you can set the sensitivity of
the mouse look on the on the game on the
FPS controller you can apply what's
called fov kick which means when you're
sprinting which it allows you to sprint
with pressing shift which multiplies
your speed it'll actually I think it'll
expand your depth of field a little bit
to make it look as if you're kind of
like colostrum phobic right like things
kind of like go out and so it looks more
narrow and it kind of gives you that
look as if you're like sprinting down a
path and you can set just how much it
increases by you can set the curve of
how that is applied here so this is one
of the components that unity allows you
to to do is there's a curve object and
you can use this curve to influence
various things in your game I actually
haven't used it much myself but if
you're looking for something to apply a
curve to unity has an interface for
making that visible within your
inspector head Bob which means when I
walk should should the camera kind of
like go up and down and when you do have
a head Bob like what's the curve look
like so here's another curve this is the
sort of what the head Bob looks like
kind of a sine wave but a little bit
distorted and a few other things so for
example footstep sounds maybe you don't
like the sounds that come by default
with the controller so you give it your
own footstep sounds super easy to do
just dragged new sounds here jump sound
and a landing sound two more sounds that
you can add to it
and that'll allow you to customize most
of the feel of how your character moves
around in terms of just a basic FPS
controller and so just by applying those
very basic things customize them a
little bit hope we got lucky with this
maze it's and this means that the maze
went all the way around and then looped
right back to where we were and ended
there so this is that's that maze okay
but I'm gonna go ahead and turn up the
sound you hear the footsteps right along
with the creepy whispering but the
footsteps are just provided to us with
us provided to us by the FPS controller
and again you can customize those to be
whatever you want and so this gives you
the ability to walk around and your
scene for a first-person view doesn't
really give you much more than that in
order to do like an FPS where you have
like maybe a gun or a weapon or
something you need to program some more
things and it's a lot more complicated
but for just basic navigation of a 3d
scene that's a great foundation a great
wood way to get started so any questions
as to how the FPS controller works there
are other controllers too there are
third-person controllers so if you want
to use those they don't come with a
camera based on my experimentation they
don't actually come with a camera by
default so I think you have to parent a
camera to them in the way that you want
for your game like for example some
games have the camera super high above
your character while you're walking
around and some of them have like a like
behind the shoulder look almost like
like fortnight or Gears of War like
really close to the character and then
some kind of have like in banjo kazooie
you could be walking up a mountain and
so the camera is kind of like
perpendicular to where you are and so
that follows you around so camera
programming for 3d characters is a
little bit more complicated than it is
for first-person games and so that's why
I mentioned it doesn't come with a
camera by default so it can be a little
bit more complicated but I do believe
there are a lot of assets on the asset
store that can help bootstrap you if
you're getting a programmatic camera
setup going for your character in a 3d
third-person view yeah
yeah yep
that I believe that's a result of the
collider being a little bit too big so
what what he said was that they walking
through the maze you can kind of clip
through the wall a little bit see if we
can actually experience it yeah right
there yes and that's the I believe
that's just the the camera or the
Coolatta the collider being a little bit
too large and so probably like get rid
of that all together just by shrinking
the collider a little bit just a detail
that I didn't tire now but you'll see
that a lot of games actually a lot of
games have like clipping that you can
get that you can observe depending on
how they've programmed the game but yeah
any other questions as to how character
controllers are work and ech how the
import process works and how to get it
in your scene okay
cool yeah it's super easy again here's
what the FPS control looks like capsule
Collider with a camera and then the
third person controller by default to
give you a pretty nice looking model on
the left side there so that you can
experiment with it and then they
apparently give you an AI one as well so
you can test AI and your scene with it
but I haven't experimented too much with
that to vouch for how well it works so
an important aspect of today's example
is that we've gone from having just one
scene having two scenes so I want to
illustrate how we sort of move between
the scenes a little bit and also I
realize we didn't really cover the
dungeon generator in code detail but
notice that I have exposed a lot of
things here a floor prefab wall prefab
ceiling prefab these are just the the
cubes that are textured to be our floor
walls and ceiling we can just click and
drag them from the inspector into our
scene onto the components there we have
a character controller reference here so
that we can place the character
controller in our scene when we've
generated the first block we can
basically take the transform and set its
position to whatever that X Z is and
then a floor parent and a walls parent
so the reason that we have parent
objects actually which we didn't look at
before whoops I've lost track of where
my there
the reason that we have parent objects
here is because when we instantiate all
of the cubes in our scene just sort of
you know just instantiate them without
we're thinking about it it ends up
basically I'll show you here well first
of all I don't know what this is
I think it's oh because I clicked on the
floor parent right okay so you click on
the walls parent actually I didn't do it
yet but it'll actually show you where
all of the all the objects that are
parented or that are dependent on that
parent so the floor parent here see how
many floor blocks there are it's quite a
lot excuse me there's a lot of floor
blocks here and in the walls parent
there's even more there's a lot of walls
and ceiling blocks and if we just
generate those without assigning them a
parent it'll just fill up our hierarchy
they're very messily and it makes
navigating our scene during debugging
very difficult right we don't need to
see that we have a million clones of the
floor or the ceiling blocks or the wall
blocks and so what we do is we just take
though all of the cloned blocks and we
just parent them to an object and when
you parent something to an object you
get that little drop down like for
example this first person character this
FPS controller is the parent of this
first person character as those are two
separate objects that both comprise the
FPS controller effectively a parent is
top level and it's children are
therefore within it within this little
arrow here and it's collapsible all of
the things within the play scene for
example the play scene is the parent to
all of these it's sort of like a folder
hierarchy type of thing and so if you
want to clean up your scene if your
instantiate a ton of things just
effectively containerize them by putting
them into a parent object and so we do
that in our game with a function called
create child prefab that's what create
child prefab does is it does an
instantiation as normal right creates a
prefab instantiates it gives it a
position
XYZ quaternion identity because we don't
want to apply any rotation to it but my
pre for prefab transform dot parent
equals parent transform the effectively
linking our we're assigning the parrot
field of our of that prefabs transform
to the parents transform and that has
the effect of basically linking them
together in a parent-child relationship
and that will allow us to collapse and
expand a list when one parent has a
bunch of children we can expand it and
contract it in the hierarchy view and
save us a lot of save us a bit of a
headache in terms of navigating our
scene when we instantiate a lot of
things which is fairly normal
so the actual may I'll go over this
fairly quickly it's a fairly simple
algorithm and I've talked about it on
the screen and we don't have a ton of
time but basically we go Z to X the
reason that we go Z to X is because in
unity Z and X are sort of like the
ground axes and Y is sort of like the up
and down axis and so we don't want to
instantiate we're not really worried
about navigating the y axis during our
maze generator because all we're going
to do is instantiate four blocks along
the y axis during that phase right so
we're basically taking our 2d array and
we're iterating over it X Y and then
we're mapping that to unities ZX or XZ
if that makes sense because notice the
like this is our ground right so the way
this transform is you can see the ground
how this is X the blue is Z and Y is
this axis here we're generating we're
effectively only concerned about
generating on the ground and then when
we generate a wall we just generate it
four blocks high on the Y we don't think
about the Y so that's why x and y for
our 2d array but x and z for applying
that array to unities
3d coordinate system does that make
sense
okay so we're iterating over Z and X and
then we're indexing into our map data Z
and X which is effectively the same
thing as Y and X and then we are
creating a child prefab if map data Z X
so recall if so recall that our map data
is a 2d array of boolean s-- right and
so if we have map data Z X equal to true
that means there's a wall there it means
that that there's a true in our array so
we should instantiate a wall at that
location so we create three wall prefabs
assign them to the walls parent so that
they get containerized within there so
it'll clog up our hierarchy view and
then see here and so if we don't so if
we've if we've gone to our maze right if
we're generating our maze and we get to
our first tile that's actually not a
wall so it's an empty space so it
basically the else here so if map data
is the XS not true it's gonna be false
so if that's the case and if not
character placed so character place is
just a boolean it's a private boolean we
don't want this to be visible in our
inspector there's no purpose for it to
be visible in our inspector this is just
a boolean for us to use in our script so
we set that to false by default because
we haven't placed our character yet but
once we when we generate our maze we
have to make sure we put our character
in a spot that there isn't a wall
because we don't want them trapped in a
wall or clipping through them in the
maze right so if not character placed
we're going to set the character
controller's transform we're in a sense
position and rotation which is a
function we're gonna set it to X and
then y1 and then Z and then no rotation
so quaternion dot identity and then set
that to true so therefore this will
never be called again so this only gets
called them a very first empty space
that we go through our maze and that's
it for that
when we no matter what we do whether
there's a wall in our maze or not we're
gonna want to generate a floor and a
ceiling at that space so that's of
course assuming that generate roof is
true which recall we made a public
boolean in our inspector so that I could
debug and show you guys what the maze
looks like from up above
so if generate roof create a child
prefab for a ceiling prefab at x4z so a
bit higher up and then no matter what
always want a floor so create a floor
prefab at X 0 Z so down below and our
character controller gets placed at
recall X 1 Z so just above the floor the
assignment is actually part of the
assignment is generate a hole in the
floor and if there's a hole in the floor
and the character falls through the fool
or the hole should get a game over right
so you're gonna create a game over scene
or I need to transition to that scene
and then we're going to need to check to
see whether the characters transform has
gone below a certain amount right that's
all fairly easy stuff to do
that you'll look to do some of that in
here and then the actual maze data
function is here I won't go over it in
detail but it's the algorithm that we
talked about before where we choose
direction and move randomly and which is
a random number of steps to move clamp
that value within the constraints of the
maze and then set every tile that we
explore to false and then I was the
effect of creating the maze and then we
just return that data back to our
function is just a 2d array
notice that in unity to our sorry in
c-sharp to create a 2d array it's a
little bit different than in a lot of
other languages it has its own instead
of syntax for that you have the array
syntax that you're probably familiar
with but then you also have this comma
and that comma is to designate that
there are two arguments to that index
syntax here just means there an X should
go here why I should go there basically
or why X and that's 2d array and you can
make it you can make it as many degrees
as you want to just add more commas to
it and there's that two actually
allocate the memory that we want for
that 2d array new bull may sighs may
sighs so our mazes always square-shaped
same same and you could easily make this
a sex maze y if you wanted to to make it
like rectangular so you just need to
have two public variables instead of one
and all of this is fairly visible
through the inspector to in our dungeon
generator you can see I made a tiles to
remove 350 so that means that our maze
is gonna cut out 350 tiles and as soon
as it cuts out 350 tiles it's done and
then our may size as 30 by 30 so that
means there's gonna be 900 tiles in our
maze so you can tailor this to whatever
you want in order to produce sparse or
denser mazes to your liking so any
questions as to how the code for that
works more or less
so now we'll actually get to the scenes
part of it and so transitioning between
oh yeah yeah
objects in like the ceiling instead of
like a hole oh yeah
so for a small game is it ideal more
ideal for the walls to be rendered as
like one one discrete object as opposed
to like several cubes yeah absolutely
that's a hundred percent true and
actually minecraft is an example of this
sort of idea that you think would work
but they actually consolidate all their
geometry after they've generated it in
this way and produce like models that
are more optimized like that you think
that you're interacting with its world
that's a bunch of these little blocks
all separate but it's actually one big
piece of geometry and then it
dynamically figures out why you're
hitting and removes and adds blocks as
needed and there's some some cool videos
on YouTube as to how to do this in unity
to which I looked at a long time ago and
it kind of shows you you can actually
dynamically create meshes and vertices
and stuff in unity and then create
objects that way which is really cool
but that's a little bit more on the
advanced side but yeah absolutely for an
actual implementation of this a simple
but more efficient way to do it would
just be to have like yeah one solid
large wall object that's like as tall as
you need to be and maybe as wide as you
need it to be for one character and have
that work but for simplicity sake and
illustrate the algorithm we were just
using the cubes yeah exactly but yeah
good point that's a hundred percent true
all right multiple scenes so the way
that we do this so I'm going to go into
my text editor whoops
so the
grab pickups script so grab pickups is a
component that's attached to the
character controller because he's going
to be picking up pickups and what the
grab pickup script effectively does is
the character controller built in
collide has this function that you can
define for it called on controller
collider hit where anything that
collides with the controllers Collider
will trigger this callback function and
you can grab the information about the
object that you collided with and then
perform some sort of logic on that and
so it's actually calling this function
every single time we collide with any of
the tiles of the blocks and our scene as
well there's just no logic to account
for them so it's just effectively an
empty function call but if it's the case
that the game object has a tag of pickup
which we've set in our at a unity editor
and I'll show you how to do that then we
should play a sound from our pickup
sound source and then we should using we
you actually use this in the last
lecture but only within the same scene
we're going to call seam manager load
scene play and you need Unity engine dot
scene management using Unity engine that
scene management at the top of your
script in order to use this and load
scene effectively just really like we'll
literally just load a scene by its name
and we're doing that in a couple places
so we're actually doing it there but
remember we had the title scene which
had the same sort of thing you press
ENTER and you load a you load the play
scene right so this load scene on input
component that I created is attached to
a text field in the title scene and all
we're doing here is in the update we're
just saying hey if update if
input.getaxis submit is equal to 1 then
seam entered a load scene play almost
the almost the same kind of
same code only in this case we're
querying unities input it has a global
input manager get axis so it has several
axes as how it defines a different like
methods of input and then it defines
them by keywords so in this case submit
is a keyword and you define you map
those keys or you map those keywords to
specific keys and input sources on
whatever platform you're targeting in
this case submit is missed with either
enter or return depending on which
platform you're using and it could have
other meanings if we're exporting this
to Xbox or for exporting it to the web
or for exporting it to a mobile phone
there's a lot of different ways of
changes and so the way that it checks is
it'll be 0 or 1 specifically so we can
say if input.getaxis submit equals 1 see
manager load seen play and it won't let
you do if input dot get access submit
because it's explicitly expecting an
integer and it'll throw an error if
you're trying to use it like a boolean
so we need to use this equals equals 1
to test for equivalence and that's all
we're effectively doing there now the
interesting thing is when we reload the
scene for the pickup right for the maze
there's a soundtrack playing in the
background and we want the soundtrack to
constantly be playing the same thing and
to loop right the sound effect we don't
want it to start up immediately again
start up like from the very beginning
again we kind of want the seamless sort
of feel to it and so how do we think we
can solve this problem
correct so any ideas as to how he would
do this well so whenever we collide with
the pickup we reload the scene
completely from scratch and so when you
reload a scene it destroys every game
object in the scene including all the
objects that have audio sources attached
to them and so when it reloads the scene
it reinstates all the game objects in
the scene including those with audio
sources Andry triggers their playing so
what we want to do is prevent this from
happening that will have the effect of
so you're saying have a counter and when
so have a counter or true/false when you
load the scene it starts the music but
what happens is when we reload the scene
from scratch and the audio that was
playing gets deleted can you transport
certain objects between scenes
effectively you can there's a function
called don't destroy onload actually so
with that it's a Unity function which
allows you to preserve an object as it
is between scenes so if you don't want
your scene with the music - or your
object with the music to destroy itself
and then reinstate unload well
technically just don't destroy itself
just do don't destroy unload at the game
object and so this don't destroy we
apply this to our audio source our
whisper source it's called in the scene
the only problem with this is if we're
Ian Stan she ate there if we don't
destroy unload this object it's gonna
persevere but when we reload the scene
it's gonna instantiate a new one so
what's the effect of this gonna be I'm
gonna have two audio sources playing at
the same time what happens when we do
another one we have three audio sources
playing at the same time
so for every time you go to a next level
you're gonna add the same audio track to
the scene it's gonna be very annoying
very quickly the way that we avoid this
happening is by making what's called a
singleton so what a singleton is is a
class that can only effectively be
instantiated one time right and we do
this by creating a static variable here
called don't destroy no we called
instance which is of type don't destroy
so it's this component here right and so
they don't destroy class as a whole has
the static variable called instance and
we set it to null by default and we
haven't instantiated a don't destroy
component yet and what this ensures in
our scene by the logic we have in the
awake function awake is almost the same
thing as start just means whenever you
can you can pause an object and it'll
awake from its pause state but awake it
also gets called when an object gets
instantiated so if the instance is set
to null on awake instance equals this so
this don't destroy so whatever this is
being called from this this don't
destroy will be the instance whatever
the first don't destroy component is in
our scene the very first maze that we
generate the sound source instance will
be this and then we set don't destroy
onload for the game object that is
holding that don't destroy don't destroy
component right that audio source but if
the instance is not equal to this so if
we've awoken and this is level 2 for
example instance is going to be set to
the the don't destroy a component on
they don't destroy on load object that
we created in the first maze right
because we did this logic here and so
it's gonna try and instantiate a second
don't destroy component it's gonna
another sound source but instance is not
going to be null instance is going to be
equal to that first object so we say if
instance is not equal to this
destroy game object so this is gonna be
from the standpoint of the second just
don't destroy that got created the
singleton will persist indefinitely yeah
indefinitely upon its first
instantiation and there will only ever
be one singleton this is a very basic
very common pattern in software
engineering for ensuring that you only
have one object of a given type present
for your entire project but this is how
we prevent multiple some sources from
being instantiated we always ensure that
only one object of that with that
component gets instantiated at once in
any future instantiations of that object
get destroyed immediately assuming that
they aren't that first object if they
are that first object instance will not
instance will equal this and so it'll
still skip this part and so will stay
alive so any questions as to how the
persevering through multiple scenes
works for their sound source okay that's
how we get multiple scenes so fought we
looked at fog already but I have a few
screenshots here to kind of help
illustrate what fog has looked like over
the years so fog looks pretty
unconvincing in this screenshot this is
Tarak for the n64 it's just kind of
looks as if you know sort of at a
certain distance a very dense sheet of
fog has appeared and you can actually
make this look happen in unity by
setting the there's a curve a fog curve
that I believe you can manipulate that
well effectively the algorithm that
determines how the color gets summed to
things far away is very fast as opposed
to gradual or linear so you can make it
just like exponential effectively and
make it look as if the fog is incredibly
dense and starts almost at a very fixed
spot and have the rest of this area sort
of in front of you look normal
here's another example Star Wars the
Empire one of my favorite n64 games
which has sort of the same look and so
in this area you can see fog is very
distinguishable very artificial looking
because it's very tinted in this case it
looks very blue in this case it looks
very like pale blue
this is Silent Hill and Silent Hill
looks realer more realistic but kind of
the same thing at play here you have a
very pale gray metallic blue color
and the density in this case is very
high the density is much higher
well maybe close to as high as it is in
our game that we should that were
showing today but it's effectively the
same thing just with a different color
and they used it to great effect in here
and not only for sort of this aesthetic
to make you look as if you're in some
sort of desolate town but also to
dynamically load objects or to prevent
rendering objects that are a certain
distance away and to optimize
performance on the hardware that was
severely limited at the time which was
PlayStation 1 which is fairly weak
console and then here is Shadow of the
Colossus for ps4 which just came out not
too long ago and we can see fog is still
being used but it looks photorealistic
and there's probably a lot more that
they're doing they probably have several
layers of fog they probably have
textures and you know transparent
objects that are simulating fog and a
lot of more complicated things like that
fog that only hangs at a certain
distance so it looks like fog going over
the lake there's a lot of things here
but it's the same idea and they probably
have the same sort of foundational base
fog present throughout the scene and
then here's our game just to show how it
looks like and barely even see it but it
does give you this sort of like lost in
a really dangerous maze feeling which
and it's super easy to do and it can it
can save you performance and it can add
a lot of aesthetic to your game and so
the last big thing we'll talk about
today is unity 2d actually so I'm gonna
go back into a questions about fog I
know that was a pretty high-level
overview of all ready looked at fog we
looked at how it applies in the settings
any questions is how it works or how to
get its work in unity okay so we're
gonna go ahead and look at our title
scene and so we looked at this earlier
briefly but I'm going to go ahead and
show you the components so I'm gonna
take a look at our canvas if you double
click on something you'll sue mout and
so it'll automatically detect our what
your resolution is and scale the canvas
accordingly in your scene view there's a
2d button here I'm going to go ahead and
go to my default layout I'm gonna click
on the canvas notice that it shifted
things a little bit because now I have a
larger window that's gonna be rendered
too I'm gonna click on the canvas
and then I'm going to go into 2d mode
and then notice when you click on 2d and
3d mode you go like instantly into like
seeing it as if you're manipulating it
in a 2d engine versus a 3d engine and
then going back to 3d now it's a three
dimensional plane that you're looking at
so in 2d mode you can easily sort of
navigate it right click and drag it
around I'm gonna go here like this and
these are very simple components that
you can just interact with as a GUI now
the main thing that you need to get any
of this to work is the canvas which is
here so if you right click and then go
to UI you can go to canvas if you want
to or you can just add any of these
things that you want and it'll
automatically add a canvas for you
because a canvas is necessary for all of
the unity UI rendering stuff so if I
were to just add a text and on an empty
scene it'll just create a brand new
canvas and an event system the event
system is just how unity talks to the
canvas and the all the UI elements of
your canvas given mouse and keyboard
input and stuff like that it's nothing
that you necessarily have to worry about
or use but the canvas is the sort of
overall container for all gooey stuff
that you do now if I click on the title
text or the enter text notice that they
are children of the canvas so they are
within the canvas the canvas is their
parent the title text I can move it
around notice that it snaps right it's
got some nice snapping functionality I
can set it up there it'll snap to the
top it'll yeah it's pretty handy you can
scale or scale the the bounding box it
doesn't scale the actual text but the
notice that I do have like right
justification centering left
justification those sorts of helping the
sort of features I can increase the font
size via a slider right so I can
immediately see without having to edit
some code and then reload the project
what changing some of these values will
look like I can easily change the color
in real time so I can get a sense of how
that looks if you wanted some sort of
slimy dread 50
look I guess and you can also assign
materials to it as well which is kind of
cool which I haven't explored in too
much in detail but you have that option
if you want to give it a material
instead of a instead of a color material
font because ultimately all this stuff
is still 3d but unity presents it in a
way that makes it look as if you're
interacting with it in 2d it's pretty
nice yep so the transition to the rest
of the game is in the load scene on
input here so this script that we looked
at earlier so this is assigned to one of
those text labels so I just gave it to
the forget was that the I think it's the
enter text so I gave it this load scene
on input just because it's a it's the
enter text it seemed appropriate could
put it on anything in the scene it
doesn't matter as long as it has this
update function which then has this if
input get access submit equals 1 and
then recall the go into the project
settings in put all these axes here are
defined for you automatically and then
you can choose what they map to but
submit as you can see positive button is
returned so if submit is equal to one
room press return will be equal to one
effectively and it gets mapped to other
buttons depending on what input sources
you have on your device but you can
check what it is on your computer just
by going to axes in your input manager
so it's once again edit project settings
input and then you can see all the axes
here
it's a scene in itself completely as a
camera so we are the camera renders the
thing about canvas is it's kind of
separate from the camera so it gets
rendered on to whatever the cameras
rendering separately but the camera in
this case what I've done because if by
default we just render the camera and
the UI it's going to look just like this
gonna look like the sky with dread 50
and press enter that's not this
aesthetic that we want so I take the
camera and then you can give it a
background so by default the background
is
sky is the skybox and so they set clear
flags clear flags that are same thing as
background so whatever there's no
geometry or anything clear what this
clear color clear flag this gets drawn
to before any geometry in the scene
basically excuse me so clear flags solid
color in this case and then just black
using a color picker so super easy super
nice and then this UI this canvas will
get drawn on top of this camera so
that's what produces the sort of
combined effect of having the the UI
text and the black background and then
that enter text having that component
that checks for the submit input because
that's what enter and return map to that
is that is what lets us transition from
the current scene to the play scene and
so there are a lot of other cool
features that these like labels and such
have for example being able to set its
anchor position so depending on what
device you're shipping to you might want
your you know you're gonna have multiple
screen sizes and screen resolutions so
you can say I want this label to always
be at the very top middle of my scene
and I can do this by clicking this
little box here which is the Anchor
Point selector and then just clicking
that and so that will always anchored
red 50s text at the top middle no matter
what our resolution is it'll always be
there and there's a lot that you can do
whoops on top of that and you can set
with any UI component just relative
positioning depending on the resolution
and the nice thing about unity - if you
go to game you can actually choose sorry
in the second menu you can choose a lot
of aspect ratios so five four doesn't
look that great 4:3 doesn't look that
great
16:10 16:9 and then standalone so
stand-alone is the default export size
of your platform
but you can choose you can have it you
can test different resolutions and you
can also add more - you can add a fixed
resolution if you want or an aspect
ratio and do a lot of cool things that
way so you don't have to necessarily
test it physically on different devices
although it's very good - so you can
make sure that you're not blowing up
your hardware but you have that option
so any questions as to how unity 2d
works and how the canvas works or how
we've gotten the simple UI to work part
of the assignment will be and we'll take
a look at that now actually so
assignment 9 we talked about this
already about the gaps in the floor but
this will be part of you know the maze
generator right because it's where we
generate ultimately or the generates the
maze instantiate err
the actual part of the maze generator
that creates the physical maze but
create gaps in the floor and then when
the player falls through approximately
two blocks below which so you can set
makes you check the transform is the Y
positions less than a certain amount
right should be yeah should be less than
zero I think it's based on the top part
of it then you should transition to a
new screen that says game over so create
a new scene very similar to the first
scene that we looked at which was just
the title screen and you can probably
copy most of that but that scene should
say game over and then pressing enter
there should load the title scene right
and then lastly add a text object to the
play scene that just keeps track of how
many levels you've navigated through and
you can probably do this with some kind
of static variable but any solution that
accomplishes it is welcome but
altogether all pretty easy pieces to put
together that was this week which was
dread halls and our first foray into
first-person games next week we'll look
at portal it won't look necessarily this
good but it'll look similar to this this
is a screenshot from portal itself but
we'll look at how we can render two
textures how we can cast rays from our
character our first-person controller
how we can actually make it look as if
we have a weapon or gun or portal gun
which is you know not too difficult you
just have to
basically a model tier first-person
controller and then when we walk through
a portal how do we transition from the
other two from one portal to the other
portal so just a you know teleport your
transform to another position but that
was that next week is portal and I will
see you all next time